Downing Street has taken aim at the BBC
confirming they're considering scrapping
the licence fee for a subscription model
and forcing the sale of most of its
radio now to be clear the BBC is an
iconic British brand it must not however
be held up to be infallible and
untouchable the corporation has become
analogous to many US tech giants
undeniably bloated squeezing out local
competition and stifling startup
innovation such near monopoly power is
unfairly subsidised by a regressive flat
tax that outrageous outrageously makes
it a criminal offense not to pay for the
licence fee for watching any live
programme on any device even if not a
BBC show the licence fee is simply
unfair unprogressive and unsustainable
it belongs firmly in the top-down world
of the last century yes
let's ring-fence the BBC's world-class
news and current affairs but it should
never be criminal for refusing to pay
for entertainment if you don't consume
it resisting change here can only be
done by mounting a nostalgic
conservative defense of the status quo
but since when is that progressive topic
I think the discussion no I think the
discussion about the licence fee is a
very valid one in the sense that if
someone came along to Dyer so we got to
invent this then we're going to have a
television in your house you will have a
pie 150 odd pounds tax which we can use
for programming it would have no chance
yeah we have no chance however when you
start looking at all the alternatives
it's quite difficult well what what
matters I think and this is what you the
conclusion I reached after sort of four
years of overlooking universality that
this is available to everybody
yeah and that matters I think I think
that you haven't you have a set of
services that are available to everybody
I mean I've seen some of the criticisms
I
if instance the Sunday Times motor
leader basically saying they've closed
down local local newspapers you know
know what's closed down local newspapers
is the advertising model for local
newspapers
it's defunct it's gone because actually
all those ads now go online and that's
what happened to local news 9 to do with
the BBC there is I think a process that
we need to go through that requires a
long thought-out
Commission probably who works out okay
what are the eternities what is the best
way of doing where mrs. Thatcher tried
to put ads on the BBC she got a might
create corner mr. do a report on it who
came out and said it won't work it won't
work and I'd like to see some more
thought going to this in particular let
me add no I'm Pro thought because some
people are thinking it's grateful for
ideological reasons and what's
interesting is this quote from Damien
green who says destroying the BBC wasn't
in our manifesto and will be cultural
vandals will forget about the cultural
vandalism bit but wasn't the destroying
there as well it's not what I'm
proposing
no no but exactly but just for the BBC
it requires how I I think you know
people talk there's a hysteria around
this we're not going to lose the BBC
it's just gonna be put on the same
commercial footing hopefully as as other
companies that okay how do you put local
radio BBC local yeah any sort of
commercial capital let me tell you it
won't play well if it won't pay for
itself is it that's the difference
that's the discussion I didn't want to
but let me finish about the projects a
point about profligacy and and it's you
know we have you know we read day after
day about this the scores of executors
on to and 300 grand a year
they're gold-plated pensions when they
get a payoff to get three years money
plus the go play to pension and and you
know if they make a mistake like they
did with a digital media plan
for much cost 100 million quid most
commercial companies would suffer
because of the BBC just wipe their face
and move on because they know the next
year there's a truckload of licensed
repaint fee money coming from
I don't see why great things is
ideological anyway to object to the fact
the state is ordering people to pay
attacks to watch a form of media which
they may not actually draw why should
the state be taxing at the commercial
disadvantage of them that was and count
says about the size of beauty I remember
in seeing Mark Thompson directed the
general the BBC and said how many people
does the BBC employ he didn't have a
clue and he told me this story which
underlies the problems at the BBC when a
BBC hostage who'd been in captivity in
the Middle East for a couple of years
had been released
he got one call from Sky to fix up an
interview 38 calls from the BBC
different outlets to do the same we do
it is out of control and it's out of
control because it's got a state
guarantees substitute as well as the
current director of creative diversity I
think what we must not lose sight of is
the fact that our BBC is the envy of the
world when you speak to broadcasters
around the world they ask completely
envious that we have something like news
that we have all of them that we have an
institution like this and also it is the
engine of our creative industry if you
look at the relationship with the
independent sector in terms of
independent production companies the BBC
is the biggest buyer so actually if the
BBC goes our creative industry kijun I
think people make that correlation a bit
of information on this please it's it's
50s have been a 50% increase in the
number of European productions made by
Netflix what we buy they are catching we
called it a state broadcaster but it's
you know the BBC doesn't what they might
not but everyone in Boston is nationally
by the day okay okay so it's supposed to
be it's a state broadcast in the sense
that we all pay a tax to watch it
however we died okay it's had to pay a
tax to watch something of I don't think
is broadly representative sustainable so
can I know I'm in the middle of the
point I just want to say that you know
the the the baby say has been roundly
criticized recently over the fact of its
left-wing bias also aspires recently
towards brexit I don't want to watch a
TV station that tells me something added
that that puts a slant on news that I
don't agree judgement about bias is
actually didn't actually put out Boris
Johnson's speech on greg's at night
whether you agree with regs it or not it
was a historic complained in the same
way it's both sides of I just want to
pick up one quick point so you said that
you do not want to pay for entertainment
that you don't consume or be
criminalized for entertainment you don't
consume you wouldn't be if you're not
consuming entertainment you're not
consuming live TV if you're consuming
any live TV on any device that it's not
a BBC protesting live TV watching live
sky and not the BBC but I'm still paying
for the BBC no but the license fees to
allow you to be able to consume
television periods on my phone I could
be watching live CNN why am i paying a
BBC licence fee for that any library any
live in would cost on any device even if
it's not a BBC programme ya have to pay
for your that's always been the case
that's right and that's what the BBC
doing so much it's just doing too much
it's too ambitious it's too big it's do
not it please attack me I have a
question for the panel if I'm a point of
principle I said I'm gonna watch live
live CNN on my iPhone and I refuse to
pay the BBC and got a criminal offence
for a crime would you sympathize with me
can I just say why can I do the same or
not give you this
from Sir David Clemente the chairman of
evil
he said the BBC is a great national
asset a diminished BBC is a weakened
united killer right sitting behind a
paywall it would no longer be the place
that brings the country together for the
strictly final hour Gavin and Stacey on
Christmas Day or the armistice
anniversary or Holocaust nor would it be
the place that all could turn to to
celebrate live important moments we
enjoy as a nation the royal wedding or
Jubilees or the olympic successes he's
right the whole thing of course is the
biggest supporters of the BBC are
actually the South of England middle
class who disproportionately vote Tory
and I suspected the Conservative Party
if a Conservative Party or a bit of the
Conservative Party tries to push this
thing through he will have enormous
opposition within they're not trying to
wreck the BBC so not what about what
Gary Lineker says he says I wouldn't
make the license fee voluntary I don't
know the logistics of how it would work
you would lose some people but at the
same time you drop the price a bit
you're forced to paid if you want a TV
and therefore it's a tax
what about obsess about that what if he
thought that if people won't pay it and
how much is he being paid by the way
well exactly yeah and it's not even
exclusive in Germany they've got they've
got a broadcasting levee and it's
composure on every household okay you're
watching the page on Sky News after the
break why we need radical action to stop
football clubs making the rule
[Music]